so you know you know what happened um
you're only allowed
to say the world is ending you're not
allowed to say hey maybe this is
overblown
because if you do you run the rest of it
banned there have been a ton of
youtubers that have been
instantly banned no strikes no warning
just gone because they'll put out a
video questioning masks or something
yeah so if you're not allowed to have
any conversation at all about maybe we
went too far
then the only thing anyone ever sees is
the end is nigh
it's getting worse it's getting worse
when if you actually look at the data
you're like oh man we flattened the
curve a
long time ago so we saw rick desantis in
florida
he was like coveted lockdown done gone
in every capacity over
we just had in michigan they were the
supreme court of michigan ruled
all of the lockdown stuff
unconstitutional and then so what did
the governor say
don't care yeah i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna
go forward anyway because we have 21
days before this goes into effect
and apparently that's actually part of
the governor has 21 days to
appeal essentially or call for a hearing
to challenge the supreme court's ruling
if she's straight up saying well then
technically i can just keep doing
whatever i want for 21 days she's
clearly just defying the law
and that's crazy a governor basically
going rogan but so the attorney general
said nah we're not enforcing any of this
anymore so it's all breaking apart now
cuomo though in new york is going to be
re-upping all this stuff
and i think twelve thousand bars and are
expected to
be completely destroyed right yeah and
restaurants
the economy in new york is just being
just destroying it
as as to the best of their abilities and
it's cuomo's fault you know a good
portion of the deaths were nursing home
deaths and cuomo was putting sick people
in nursing homes
did you see he tried denying it yeah he
was like that never happened
and then a bunch of journalists were
like uh like this was
really recently we were able to yeah
that's what
that's what frustrates me about there
are these like blue twitter
quote journalist check marks who love to
blame as like 200 000
coronavirus deaths on trump as if
somehow trump if he were more competent
would be able to be the only country
pretty much with zero coronavirus deaths
and then also they also don't talk about
where all these deaths are coming from
places like new york right i mean no one
forced cuomo to do that
no that was like cuomo with joker makeup
on being like
if i put sick coveted people into
nursing homes
what come on man i i don't think
anyone in their right mind could assume
that
that was innocent yeah it was just an
honest mistake
i mean it's the most vulnerable
population when it comes to covid
why wouldn't i put a person who's got
who's got you know covid
into the nursing home why did he do it i
don't know
i don't think he has a real reason maybe
trying to rescue like their state
entitlement program or something i don't
know he's saying
it never happened that's the crazy thing
now he now like he did interviews like
that never happened and they're like oh
actually
nope never happened you're wrong and
they're like actually not wrong i'm
saying
wrong hey but on the upside the curve is
flattened
according to the data from months ago
it's been flat for a long time so
so we're suffering economic now but
people actually are not suffering nearly
what they were yeah like so coveted was
so
the the issue is i think we've got
really short memories in this in
this year i guess yeah before this all
kicked off
it was conservatives that were actually
the most concerned at first and i made
several videos i made a couple videos in
january
that were like approved and i was like
whoa something crazy is happening
in in wuhang and then after kovit got
crazy they actually
demonetized it after the fact because
it's like all of a sudden now you can't
talk about kovid
yeah it was really weird because it was
before it made its way here
but it was a global pandemic so it was a
mass casualty incident and then once it
became really obvious it was affecting
everybody like okay fine we're going to
monetize the content again
but so so early on conservatives were
very concerned tucker carlson flew to
mar-a-lago to talk to trump and was like
yo this is serious
so trump did all these things started
the task force ban uh travel to china
for the most part i love how they say no
he didn't because this that this okay
dude he traveled
he banned travel except for people who
are returning back
and for i think like official business
and then he put heavy restrictions on
european travel
fauci in march said what the
administration is doing is wonderful and
i don't think anyone could do better
and the new york times had this slider
bar where you could be like
if the if the percent if the mortality
rate is three percent here's somebody
dead and it's like six million
how many people are dead now 200 200
000. so here's what ends up happening
you go to these conservatives who read
that news and saw what trump was saying
and then they look at two you know the
the uh the media
like the new york times saying potential
is 2 million deaths trump says we're at
200 000 it's it's horrible but it's way
better than 2 million
the pollsters then asked the
conservative do you think two hundred
thousand dead is
acceptable yeah and they say yes it is
and then the democrats go oh
yeah oh no is is it true that
94 of those 200 000 had co-morbidities
yeah
like an average of two to three more
yeah yeah
so so what's really interesting about
the comorbidities thing is that kovid
killed them but many of these people
with all due respect were not long for
this world
covert was in their system when
something killed them no kova did kill
them
so the comorbidities means covet is the
factor
but if it was like they were they had
like terminal heart disease so they got
covered some people had uh uh advanced
renal failure yeah
right so right yeah like dude so so for
sure
and there there were some instances i
think it was in florida where like a guy
got no motorcycle accidents and they
were like oh come on
no joke no joke yeah in illinois there's
a video on this adam was going was going
nuts on this one like showing the video
being like look at what she's saying
it was a press conference where like the
one of the top medical people in the
illinois government was saying
if someone dies and then we discovered
they had covenant in the system it's a
covert death
and she goes for instance if a car
accident there's like literally
a press conference where she says this
yeah so
however however i think you've got uh
i it's there's no conspiracy it's just
people are kind of dumb
you know you know the crazy thing about
all of this stuff especially with the
conspiracy theories
is this idea that there's always someone
who's super powerful
it's like haven't these people realized
yet that you're an adult
and everyone around you is just like
equally dumb
it's like at a certain point i remember
when i was growing up i always have
questions i'd be like how does this work
how does that work
and then you know my dad always had
answers for me when i was like you know
a teenager like how does this he's like
oh well and then it got to a point where
i was like in my 20s and i'm like how
does this work and i
asked some like advanced government
questioning i have no idea and i'd be
like oh
i guess i'm an adult now i got to figure
things out for myself but that's what
that's when i kind of realized like
the the level of my understanding and
everyone else
it's like fairly equal now you know in
in various respects like i'm not gonna
pretend to be a doctor you know doctors
know more than i do
and i think a lot of people aren't
journalists and kind of think they know
everything but there's a lot of people
think they know everything
but we're getting to this point now
where it's like dude if you can't pull
off a grand conspiracy to like flub
all these numbers nationwide i don't
think they can either
they could be like wealthy and and evil
and have a lot of friends
and they're still not going to pull off
any kind of grand conspiracy what i
think really happens is that
these people are panicky lazy and dumb i
mean here's the simple solution to all
of this
people in government are ineffective
it's that's the way it is
you know if you've got a competition in
the market you might get talent
but for the most part you got people who
are like somebody died oh it has covered
on the chart they put it in and then
later someone's like hey that guy died a
motorcycle accident
ah oops happens all the time
i think panicky is a great word
panicky yeah a lot of these people are
panicking mm-hmm like did you see the
the cops arresting the pregnant woman in
australia on the beach
oh yeah oh i didn't see that no she just
screamed she's pregnant and her sister
is like she's pregnant because she
wasn't wearing a mask or something like
that yeah
and there's also been uh it was a like i
think a
child that uh gosh it was some sort of
sporting event i think she was on the
bleachers she wasn't wearing the mask
and the security guard got
like freaked out it's like okay say that
there is this huge risk of coronavirus
contaminating you because she's not
wearing a mask
is is what you want to do really get
into like a physical
confrontation with them that's why
that's why i really love the old
toilet paper videos remember that like
earlier in the year when people were
running fast yeah
so it's like we have a pandemic coming
and it is
it is a very serious illness and then a
video of like 100 people shoulder to
shoulder like brawling for toilet paper
and it's like
y'all are going to get sick yeah you
know that was a huge wake-up call for me
though because i realized a lot of
people
are living toilet paper roll to toilet
paper rolls i don't know i stock up like
i have yeah
there's a lot of it and i'm like what
are you people doing
when uh uh what we drove out to go to do
the rogan show
yeah on the way back we were in arizona
in some like little bumpkin town
we go to the gas station nobody wearing
masks everything was normal
and i was wearing a mask and i was like
oh i walked up and i was like nobody
i went to the lady the the clerk and i
was like nobody's wearing mess and she's
like yeah we don't care
i was like huh and i was like you're not
concerned about what's going on i mean
people are fighting over toilet paper
and she laughs she's like oh honey we're
preppers
yeah and it was like it was like a small
town and then she told me this funny
story she was like
i remember when we saw these videos of
people fighting over toilet paper my
husband looks at me and he goes
you think we got enough toilet paper and
she's like are you kidding we got three
months
we're preppers oh yeah yeah that's what
i mean
like liam my fiancee producer he he kind
of makes fun of me for being
a prepper because i mean i'm not
hardcore i don't have a bunker i would
if i could
but i don't right now but it's like yeah
like my family we have
water we have toilet paper we have like
medications we have
some emergency rations i would love for
more but you know we are prepared a
little bit and i did feel this little
sense of indication like haha who's
crazy now
some good things together salt and honey
yeah they never
oh yeah yeah honey for vinegar too yeah
actually some
some companies sell like uh like seed
collections all things that you can grow
like really easy
you bought one yeah yeah yeah that's
awesome yeah because we're cause we're
waiting for you know it's
i don't think covet is gonna do anything
i don't think there's gonna be any kind
of massive unrest i think
people are gonna will the asteroid into
existence to finally come
solar flare or i mean there's so many
things that could knock out the power
grid
for like six weeks or two no no no no
that's what people don't realize
this is why like okay so look i did i
did a promo several times for food
buckets like the emergency food last 25
25 years or whatever and people are like
hahaha and i'm like dude sometimes it
rains
yeah it's like you watch you watch these
videos and it's like a flood happened
and people have been trapped in their
homes for two weeks and i'm like i hope
they
have food were you guys aware like the
midwest how it got
just massively flooded earlier yeah
barely didn't get a lot of media
attention
because it's because it stuns silence
but because sometimes it rains
so like even though when we have these
disasters it's not it's not news to most
of these outlets they're like i don't
know
if we told people it was raining really
bad and there was a flood they'd be like
yeah that happens all the time
it's like it doesn't it doesn't affect
me doesn't interest me so you actually
have a lot of people this is what i
never understood about this stuff is
like
aren't you concerned that you might get
stuck in a blizzard because like that
happens all the time in the midwest
right and
it happens all the time like in canada
too and where i live i used to live like
behind a farm and in front of a slightly
bigger farm
we would lose power all the time
sometimes for days you know very common
have backup generators
food that's easy to prepare and things
like that because you just you never
know
and i feel like you know hearing people
in the city
kind of try to tell people who actually
have to deal with these situations oh
you don't need that you're just you're
being
overly precautious paranoid whatever
it's like you don't know and i think
some of them got a huge wake-up call
when the whole covid thing happened
because
yeah they bought guns and they bought
toilet paper because they're in these
little
little tiny apartments where you can't
really store anything right you can't
have food storage you can have a
generator
you can't have guns because you're not
allowed to and like yeah they're
vulnerable
they're living on top of each other and
concrete cubicles where everything
smells like sour milk yeah live in the
pod
here's yeah live in the pot bend the
knee i what i really love the most is
i'm uh when it comes to telling people
to like get a bucket of emergency food
that's the very centrist approach to
prepping so i have all these
conservatives
like laughing being like a food bucket i
got a storage facility i got a thousand
rounds per gun i got 20 guns
and i'm like okay okay i'll do better
and then the city people the leftists
are like what a
[ __ ] buying these buckets oh you're so
dumb uber eats i don't need that yeah
right yeah so but
here's what i love so uh our friend luke
over at we are change
has been doing survivalist training like
awesome he's got like he's doing like
rifle training he's filming all of it
it's pretty cool
and then someone commented tim poole's
virgin food buckets versus
luke's chad survivalist training and i'm
like okay
dude yeah it was really funny he's got
an rv we found the rv hookup
so luke come on show me how to shoot
yeah
actually my my fiance bought his first
gun
and like he was we'd done our like
firearm certification course thing
because we're in canada
they're weird with guns we've done it a
while ago but like everything going on
it kind of spurred him on to
get his own and we have we have a couple
as well and yeah i don't know it's just
it's good to be prepared personally i
don't know
you have an asian background too you can
wait on this i think i would do well
in an apocalypse because i'd eat
anything like i would eat
except milk and red wine yeah well you
know upset the tummy but i mean aside
from that i'm scrappy i think
i would do well though what does being
asian have to do with that you need
anything right
i guess well i don't know i i
my fiancee he'll like freak out about
the weirdest things like maybe that's
true like i used to
she doesn't want to eat bugs i know i
know that's like a big deal for people
they're like how could they're trying to
make us eat bugs
i agree that the pot thing is
disappointed i would totally eat bugs
i got no problem with bugs right no
problem with bugs yeah why not what
about you ian
i'd eat bugs yeah okay i want to eat
your rice yeah i wonder where to eat
grass
i think you you eat it and you'll puke
but then you eat it again
your body slowly you boil in some tea
with some lemon and some salt if you
have access to it adaptive products
right down the cellulose yeah i think
tea grass tea is the way to go but
people should be able to if we can learn
to subsist off grass
i think human rights is going to be okay
i don't think i don't i think we should
pissed off grass by having cows eat it
and then we like you know yeah so i mean
i
agree i like your philosophy i did the
carnivore diet for several months and
that was like
that was an experience it's tough i have
never felt so good in my entire life
really yeah
oh yeah like like i was telling you i
have i've had the sniffles for like
pretty much forever and i have the
immune system of a bubble boy
wow i get sick all the time um and you
know i have trouble sleeping anxiety i
like
i mean not not serious stuff but stuff
over the past couple years where i don't
feel my best but on carnivore i had
energy no problem sleeping waking up
early
i just i just felt amazing but it's sad
because i love carbs so
why did you get off the carnivore diet
because i love
and it was carbs yeah i i know i totally
am and like i went through sugar
withdrawals like you know i don't
smoke i don't drink i don't even drink
coffee so really so it's like
i i used to think that i was like pretty
like oh clean living i don't have any
addictions that's not
true like there was a point yeah i would
have stabbed a homeless person for
like pizza crust no it was bad
gluten the united states has basically
been telling us to eat it on the food
pyramid stuff because that's what is
grown in the united states
so it's like a business but it's not
corn it's good for the body
corn everything we feed we feed fish
corn
oh it's so cloggy and yeah like ooh
mucousy
but i i remember this is a big fat
everyone was doing the carnivore diet
but then everyone stopped doing it so
i'm kind of like
yeah so what is it is it just pure meat
yeah it's just pure meat and also like i
mean i'm hope
um i'm hoping that next year's the year
get pregnant um but also like as good as
i felt
i don't feel comfortable like you know
they say if you have a really
restrictive diet when you're pregnant
um it can lead to things like allergies
and stuff like that i don't want my kid
to be allergic to anything so
you know i want to like be eating
everything while i'm pregnant peanut
butter yeah exactly a lot of peanut
butter
i would shrimp yeah yeah all the big
allergens thai food basically yeah
exactly
i was gonna say thai food yeah man i'd
be miserable if i was largely peanut
butter because like peanut butter is
just it's the best the best put on
everything
yeah how did we get into this
conversation like what did you do i
remember surviving
toilet paper toilet paper yes apocalypse
toilet paper
speaking of what kind of power structure
do you have in your house do you use
solar now
oh right right right now we just use
regular but my fiance and i so he's
indigenous and they have his tribe they
have essentially
a thing where they'll give you land if
you build on it
um right just like here's some land go
ahead and it's
by this beautiful beautiful lake it's
like a lakefront property
um so we we've been looking at like
prefab houses over there you don't pay
any taxes
so we've been looking at prefab houses
to put up there and like you know i
would love to get solar or something up
there and kind of be off the grid
like a modular shipping container
super high tech well actually they have
really really nice prefab houses now
like they have ones with like stone
detailing they have ones that are like
two
stories they have like really really
beautiful ones that you wouldn't even
tell were prefab but they're just
cheaper because they you know they build
them in bulk
have you guys have you guys seen the the
3d printed house thing
the videos yeah yeah it's like a
gigantic machine that sprays concrete
and then it just like draws the house
and then they frame over it it's crazy
awesome yeah we're on the verge of
something big yeah unless you know we
get wiped out by civil war or the
apocalypse a solar flare that would also
be
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you